You have made your biggest mistake of the day by clicking on SmartLess. We've got some very questionable entertainment coming up with a mystery guest to a couple of morons, so I guess enjoy SmartLess. I ate a whole bar of toffee. Really? Yeah. Wait, what is, so toffee is not taffy. But it's a hard crunchy, I only know, so it's peanut brittle without the peanuts, is
点击 SmartLess，绝对是你今天犯下的最大错误。接下来，我们会为两个笨蛋安排一些非常可疑的娱乐环节以及一位神秘嘉宾，所以，大家就好好享受 SmartLess 吧。我吃了一整块太妃糖。真的吗？对。等等，什么叫，所以太妃糖不是软糖。但它是硬且脆的，我只知道，所以它是没有花生的花生脆，对
that right? I think so, something like that. For dummies? Sure. Yeah, for dummies. Seriously, toffee, have I ever, oh no wait, toffee is that chewy gooey, it's like caramel, right? No, it's crunchy.
吧？我想是的，差不多吧。为白痴准备的？当然。对，为白痴准备的。说真的，太妃糖，我有没有，哦不等等，太妃糖那种又耐嚼又黏糊，就像焦糖一样，对吧？不对，它是脆的。
It's like brittle. It can be brittle. Yeah. Right, so it's peanut brittle without the peanuts. I think so, with just the butter or something. I've never seen it sold by itself, toffee. It's so good. Look at the look on his face when he's...
就像花生脆。它可以是脆的。对，所以它就是没有花生的花生脆。我想是的，只加了黄油什么的。我从没见过单独卖太妃糖的。太美味了。看看他吃的时候那个表情……
Yeah, where'd you get that? He's so mad, look at the jealousy. My niece is leaving tomorrow, she just walked in the door said, thank you for the treat. Here's some toffee for your troubles. Here's some toffee. Yeah. Yeah, some toffee for your troubles. She's the worst house guest ever.
对，你从哪弄来的？他气死了，看那嫉妒的眼神。我侄女明天要走了，她刚走进门说，谢谢你的款待。这里有些太妃糖，当是给你添麻烦的谢礼。这里有些太妃糖。对。对，一些给你添麻烦的太妃糖。她是有史以来最差的房客。
By the way, are you, what are you crazy? She knows what he wants. Yeah. Exactly. That is a goal. She's a good house guest. Right? Yeah, she's the best.
话说回来，你是，你疯了吗？她知道他想要什么。对。没错。这简直是满分。她是个好房客。对吧？对，她是最棒的。
She learned from the best. She learned from Tracy, friend of the show. I took my nails too. Ew, she left you her nail clipper? It's disgusting. No, I just clipped my nails because we only have like 15 minutes in between shows. Where have you put the dead nails? Right here in this napkin.
她青出于蓝。她跟节目之友特雷西学的。我也顺便剪了指甲。额，她把她的指甲刀留给你了？太恶心了。不，我只是剪了指甲，因为我们在节目间隙只有大约15分钟。你把剪下来的死皮指甲放哪了？就在这个餐巾纸里。
Ew. Oh my God. What are you supposed to do with them? How often do you clip your... First of all, you don't need to do it on camera. What are you doing? How often do you clip your nails? What?
额。天哪。不然你指望怎么处理？你多久剪一次……首先，你不需要在镜头前剪。你在干什么？你多久剪一次指甲？什么？
Will. Have you lost... Yeah. How often do you clip your toenails? As needed. Really? So what is that? Like once every two weeks?
威尔。你疯了……对。你多久剪一次脚指甲？需要的时候。真的吗？那大概是多久？比如每两周一次？
Something like that? It's like a month. It can be. Sometimes I go, if I go, look, wow, they're growing really quickly. That means that I'm like really healthy and they're just very white and very, you know, very firm. Okay. That's enough.
差不多吧？大概一个月吧。也有可能。有时候我会去，如果我去，看，哇，它们长得真快。那就说明我非常健康，而且它们长得很白，你知道的，非常结实。好了。够了。
So you're doing it yourself. You're not going to a salon. No. Like, it's like, Sean, do you go and you, do you get your feet taken care of and your hands taken care of or are you a self-care guy? I'm a self-care guy with my nails and my feet, nails and my hands and my feet, but I usually go like a month. I do like a pedicure.
所以你自己剪。你不去美甲沙龙。不。就像，肖恩，你会去，你会去护理你的脚和手吗，还是说你是个注重自我护理的人？我是个注重自我护理的人，美甲和足疗，指甲、手和脚我都会护理，但我通常一个月去一次。我会做个足疗。
When's the last pedicure you had? Well, don't lie. No one's listening. It's just you and me and Sean. No, it was before 2020 and before that, it was quite a long time. There was a period there about 15 years ago, no longer. I'm not really interested in the sincerity I'd serve, so you don't need to fucking lean back in your chair.
你上一次做足疗是什么时候？行了，别撒谎。又没人听。只有你、我和肖恩。不，那是2020年之前的事了，再之前的话，是很久以前了。那段时间大约是15年前，甚至更久。我对你表现出的真诚没兴趣，所以你不需要他妈的往椅背上靠。
You don't want me to look off into space. Yeah, because it's not really acceptable for men to have like a steady routine of manicure, pedicure. I've only had a half dozen of them in my life. I disagree. What do you mean it's not acceptable? Of course it's acceptable. I think it's just not as common as you think.
你是不想让我目视远方吧。对，因为男人如果有一套固定的美甲和足疗日常，这在社会上其实不太能被接受。我这一生只做过半打左右。我不同意。你什么意思，怎么就不能接受了？这当然能接受。我觉得这只是没有你想的那么普遍。
I think it's excessive male self-care. What are you talking about? We produced the documentary that we were in. Right. In a joke, like it's like, here's a documentary about all the freaky things that some weird dudes do to self-groom. What was that? All you need to do is just do what you're doing, Sean, is have one of those $2 little
我觉得这是男性的过度自我护理。你在说什么？我们制作过一部纪录片，我们自己就在里面。没错。像个笑话一样，就像是，这是一部关于某些怪咖为了自我修饰而做出的各种诡异行为的纪录片。那是什么？你唯一需要做的，肖恩，就是准备一把那种两美元的小
clippers there or if you're talented with your teeth like I am, you do a little tasteful, no pun intended nibble on your fingernails. That's unacceptable. All right. Well, this is a great segue. I guess. It's a perfect segue. No.
指甲刀，或者如果你像我一样对自己的牙齿很有信心，你可以优雅地——没有双关的意思——轻咬你的指甲。这太让人无法接受了。好吧。好吧，这真是一个绝妙的过渡。我觉得。这绝对是个完美的过渡。不。
Okay, so we got with us today a writer, director, producer of the highest level, okay? After bursting onto the scene with hits like Ninja Code, The Origami Master and Evil Demon Golf Ball from Hell, this man has consistently received praise and respect for each of his films while simultaneously selling lots of tickets and popcorn. It's not easy to do both those things. He's got an Academy Award nomination, a diploma from USC Film School, a wife named Karina, a bright future and a blinding present. You know him from his film Star Wars, The Last Jedi, but you love him from his film Knives
好吧，今天来到我们节目的是一位最高水准的编剧、导演兼制片人，好吗？在凭借《忍者代号》、《折纸大师》和《地狱邪恶恶魔高尔夫球》等热门作品横空出世后，这位男士一直因其每一部电影而广受赞誉和尊敬，同时还卖出了大量的电影票和爆米花。要把这两件事都做好可不容易。他获得过奥斯卡奖提名，拥有南加州大学电影学院的文凭，有一个名叫卡里娜的妻子，前途无量，现在也光芒万丈。你通过他的电影《星球大战：最后的绝地武士》认识了他，但你是因为他的电影《利刃出鞘》而爱上他的。
Out. Folks. What? This is Ryan Johnson. Ryan, please join us. Oh my God. No way. Oh my God.
各位。什么？这位是瑞安·约翰逊。瑞安，请加入我们。天哪。不会吧。天哪。
Okay. Take it easy, Sean. Take it easy, Sean. Ryan. Oh my God. Do you want to know what's so wild? I was like, who is this guy? This guy's amazing.
好了。放轻松，肖恩。放轻松，肖恩。瑞安。天哪。你知道最疯狂的是什么吗？我当时想，这家伙是谁？这家伙太棒了。
Right? I try to get a meeting with you and you're like, I think he's acting Star Wars. Yeah. And I was like, ah. Yeah. He's busy. He's busy. Welcome, Ryan.
对吧？我试图约你开个会，然后你说，我觉得他在拍《星球大战》。对。然后我就想，啊。对。他很忙。他很忙。欢迎，瑞安。
Thank you for having me. Thank you for coming. This is so wild. You look like you've got a fairly professional setup there. Yeah. You're quite adept at the podcasting. So I'm in my wife's podcast studio right now. My wife Karina Longhurst.
谢谢你们邀请我。谢谢你能来。这太疯狂了。你看起来那里有一套相当专业的设备。对。你对播客驾轻就熟。我现在在我妻子的播客工作室里。我妻子卡里娜·朗赫斯特。
She has a podcast. She does. Yeah. It's called You Must Remember This. It's like a Hollywood history podcast. It's your wife? Yeah. That's her.
她有一个播客。她确实有。对。它叫《你必须记住这些》。有点像好莱坞历史播客。那是你妻子？对。就是她。
Yeah. I tried. We tried to get into business with her. Uh-huh. She couldn't make her deal, huh? No, she's tough. What happened? Nobody in their family wants to have anything to do.
对。我试过。我们曾试图和她开展业务。呃-huh。她没谈成，是吧？不，她很强硬。发生什么事了？她家里谁都不想跟……
My household is just hero for two, Sean. Just denied you, Sean. Try their dogs. I mean, it's such a fan of that podcast. It's such a great idea. And she's got an interesting history too, right? L.A. Weekly Film Editor. Yeah.
我的家里只有英雄惜英雄，肖恩。直接拒绝了你，肖恩。去试他们的狗吧。我是说，我是那个播客的超级粉丝。这是一个绝妙的主意。而且她也有段有趣的经历，对吧？《洛杉矶周报》电影编辑。对。
She was a critic. She was the main. When we met, she was the main critic for the weekly and for the Village Voice. Wow. Yeah. Now, how did you meet? Like at a junket? No.
她曾是个影评人。她是主力。我们相遇时，她是该周报和《乡村之声》的主力影评人。哇。对。那么，你们是怎么认识的？在记者会上吗？没有。
Well, we kind of knew each other online, but then we first met. Yeah. She was like paid 500 bucks to like drive out to the middle of Jersey and do a Q&A with me. And we kind of flirted and from an audience full of old people who were there to see a free movie. Could you sense that the flirt was on there on stage during the Q&A? Yeah, but we didn't actually get together until like a year later because she lived
嗯，我们算是在网上认识的，但我们第一次见面。对。她当时拿了500美元报酬，开车跑到泽西岛中部去采访我并主持一个问答环节。我们当时有点调情，那是一群来看免费电影的老年观众。你当时在舞台上的问答环节中能感觉到这种调情吗？对，但我们直到大约一年后才真正在一起，因为她住在
in New York. And L.A. and so it wasn't until she moved back home to L.A. that we actually got together. And you already knew each other online a little bit. That sounds, is that as grimy as it sounds like? No, no, no. There was never, there was no grime pre-getting together. Right. We were just friends.
纽约。而我在洛杉矶，所以直到她搬回洛杉矶老家后，我们才真正走到了一起。而且你们之前在网上就已经有点认识了。听起来，这有它听起来那么猥琐吗？不，不，不。在走到一起之前，绝对没有任何猥琐。对。我们只是朋友。
After getting together, plenty of grime. We were just friends. So much. Well, thank you, thank you, thank you for agreeing to do this. It was a pleasure. It was very, very, very cool. Well, let's, let's, let's, let's jump in with, now, Annie Hall inspired you to become a director.
走到一起之后，那可就太猥琐了。我们只是朋友。非常。好吧，谢谢，谢谢，谢谢你答应来做客。这真是个荣幸。这非常、非常、非常酷。好吧，让我们，让我们，让我们从——现在，安妮·霍尔启发你成为了一名导演。
Oh yeah. What, what, what was it about, there's so many things about that movie that I'm sure everybody listening allows. Tracy, Tracy, the name of the movie was Annie Hall, not a person. Right. Yes. Thank you for that. Tracy, you never underestimate the thickness of Tracy Brown, sorry, just bear with us.
哦，对。有什么，关于它的什么，那部电影里有太多东西，我相信所有听众都允许。特雷西，特雷西，那部电影的名字叫《安妮·霍尔》，不是一个人。对。是的，谢谢你提醒。特雷西，永远不要低估特雷西·布朗的迟钝，抱歉，大家担待一下。
So what about Annie Hall said to you, I got to go do this? Well, I, I should, I don't know if you guys have on like your Wikipedia pages, something like this. I was interviewed for like a book that's like the movie that inspired you to become a filmmaker years ago. Oh. And I was like, what about this movie? And they're like, well, that was already taken.
那么，《安妮·霍尔》的什么地方对你说，我必须去拍电影？嗯，我，我应该，我不知道你们的维基百科页面上有没有类似这样的东西。多年前我曾为一本书接受过采访，那本书是关于“启发你成为电影人的电影”。哦。然后我就在想，这部电影怎么样？然后他们说，哦，那个已经被选了。
Like, what about this movie? Got it. So we got, I do love Annie Hall. I think Annie Hall is a great, great, great, great movie, but right now it's like. But that wasn't the one. Well, there were like a bunch of them. What was the one? What was the one they said was already taken?
就像，那这部电影呢？明白了。所以我们有，我确实很喜欢《安妮·霍尔》。我认为《安妮·霍尔》是一部非常、非常、非常、非常伟大的电影，但现在就像是。但那部不是。嗯，有很多部。那部到底是什么？他们说已经被选走的那部是什么？
And you know, the reality is that probably like a lot of people kind of like our age, like there were kind of the, the movies as a kid that actually probably like and did the inspiring and those were like the Ambulan movies and those were E.T. and Star Wars. But then you, I got, you get to film school and then you discover Fellini and you discover Scorsese and you discover the Cohen brothers and you kind of, you know, and so there's kind of that round of them. Yeah. Jason, talk about when you discovered Fellini go.
你知道，现实情况是，可能就像我们这个年纪的很多人一样，小的时候看的那些电影其实才是真正起到启发作用的，比如安布兰公司的电影，也就是《E.T.外星人》和《星球大战》。但后来你，我到了，你进了电影学校，然后你发现了费里尼，你发现了斯科塞斯，你发现了科恩兄弟，然后你，你知道的，所以大约就是那一轮电影。对了。杰森，讲讲你是什么时候发现费里尼的，开始。
Go. Yeah. Listen, I was, I was on the off the coast of, of Crete, actually. Yeah. It's a miracle. Like, oh my God. No, but your, your style is, I mean, it's just, you're, you're so creative with that camera and the story and how those two things in a really beautifully odd and intricate way
开始。听着，其实我当时在克里特岛海岸附近。对。这真是一个奇迹。就像，哦天哪。不，但是你的风格，我是说，太棒了，你对镜头的运用、故事以及这两者如何以一种极其美妙、奇特而又错综复杂的方式
intersect. Oh, what was there a particular film that, that did that because that's not a, that's not an easy thing to do. It's certainly not common that you went, oh God, I'd love to be. Be able to figure out how to do that because you do it in your sleep now. I don't know. I don't, there's no like, I mean, that's very kind of USA, first of all, but no, I don't think there's like one that's like a, that was kind of just like the one.
交织在一起，非常有创意。哦，有没有哪部特定的电影做到了这一点？因为这可不是一件容易的事。你当时心想，“天哪，我多希望能弄清楚怎么做到这一点”，这绝对不常见，因为你现在做这种事闭着眼睛都能行。我不知道。我不知道，这没有什么——首先，这话说得太美国风了，但我觉得没有哪一部电影就是“那部”起决定作用的电影。
It's kind of like a cloud of movies that I grew up watching, but mostly, I mean, you know what, I mean, and I don't know if you guys did this, but I kind of just grew up making movies with my friends and it wasn't kind of any kind of high aspirational like craft type thing. It was literally just how we kept ourselves busy on the weekends was just. Yeah, but there are, but there are some filmmakers that are just fine to sort of, in your case, write, write a story and then just shoot a story. Make sure we just photograph this script.
这更像是一团我从小看到大的电影，但最主要的，我是说，你知道吗，我不知道你们是不是也这样，我基本上就是和小伙伴们一起拍电影长大的，这并不是什么高尚宏伟的专业艺术追求。这纯粹就是我们周末打发时间的方式，就是。对，但有些电影人，就拿你来说，写个故事，然后把故事拍出来，这就很好了。确保我们把这个剧本拍成影像就行。
But then there are other filmmakers like, like yourself and say, like the Cohen brothers, that there's a, there's such a specificity to the, the, the composition of the frame and the movement of the camera that is looking to elevate. You're talking about elevating the material is what you're talking about. I'm going to take a lot of words out of the question. Whereas like Spielberg is, you know, not to belittle him at all, but there is a much more sort of traditional way in which that he is what a slight comparison to what the Cohen brothers are doing.
但还有其他电影人，比如你和科恩兄弟，画面的构图和镜头的运动有着一种极强的独特性，旨在提升作品的格调。你说的就是提升素材的格调，你说的就是这个。我要从这个问题里删掉很多话。而斯皮尔伯格，（并非贬低他）他在很大程度上是以一种更传统的方式在做这件事，这与科恩兄弟的做法有细微的差别。
It's certainly a different style. And so how did you decide to go one way or the other? Yeah. I mean, I would, I mean, first of all, I would, I would, I would, in terms of Spielberg in terms of what he does, like that he's actually someone that I, in terms of filmmaking style and craft, the way that he blocks scenes and the way that he shoots them, even though I'd actually, because he's not throwing the camera around in all kinds of crazy and sane, ostentatious ways, but he's covering the scenes and blocking them in such a way where it's like Michael
这绝对是另一种风格。那么你是如何决定走这条路还是另一条路的？对。我是说，首先，我，我，就斯皮尔伯格的成就而言，他实际上在电影风格和技艺方面——他调度场景的方式以及他拍摄的方式，尽管我其实因为他不会把镜头甩来甩去，搞出各种疯狂、神经质、炫耀式的花招，但他在处理和调度场景时，就像迈克尔
Kurtis. It's like watching Casa Blanca. It's so elegant and so perfect. I think there's the lost art of sort of staging that, that Spielberg has in a way that a lot of other directors don't have. Yes. But also, you know, and if you look at Close Encounters and Jaws, he, I don't see this a lot in movies where people are having multiple conversations at the same time in the same
柯蒂斯那样。就像在看《卡萨布兰卡》。它是如此优雅，如此完美。我认为斯皮尔伯格拥有那种许多其他导演所不具备的舞台调度的失落艺术。是的。但还有，你知道，如果你看过《第三类接触》和《大白鲨》，你会发现，在电影里看到多个人在同一个场景中同时进行多场对话并且互相插话，这样的情况我并不常见。
scene and talking over each other. Well, it's kind of Sean, there's a great scene in Close Encounters where he, where Richard drivers is kind of losing his mind, he's going back and forth between kind of the kitchen and the living room. You know that, you know that scene, right? Yes. And the camera just keeps moving with him and the, and the scene is about. And the kids are running back and forth.
肖恩，在《第三类接触》里有一个很棒的场景，理查德·德莱弗斯在那里有点精神崩溃，他在厨房和起居室之间来回走动。你知道那个场景，对吧？是的。镜头就一直跟着他移动，而这个场景讲的是。孩子们也在跑来跑去。
Yeah. It's about three and a half minutes long. And they're not worried about it. It's not like now. They're not worried about like, let's just get the coverage. So we got it. It's none of that shit. It's a conversation.
对。大概有三分半钟长。而且他们并不担心。不像现在。他们并不担心像“咱们赶紧把各个角度都拍到吧，好收工”。根本没有那些屁事。这就是一段对话。
And you feel like you're there. And you're really part of it. Yes. You feel like you're in it. And there's no need for anything but that because that's the most important thing. That sort of. And you don't watch it and think, oh my God, what an amazing one shot scene. You kind of forget that it's just one shot by the end of it, which is miraculous.
你会觉得你就在现场。你真的成为了其中的一部分。是的。你感觉自己身处其中。除了这个之外不需要任何别的东西，因为这才是最重要的。那种……而且你看着不会觉得：“天哪，这是一个多么惊艳的长镜头啊。”到最后你甚至会忘记这其实只是一个长镜头，这简直是奇迹。
For sure, Woody Allen did that really, really well and Robert Altman does that really well. But the Cohen brothers and something that you, I mean, you could, you can do the, the, the former as well. But the, the, the using the camera as a performer, I guess is my, is my point is a different effort. No better, no worse. It's just a different tool. And I was just wondering if there was a, a film.
当然，伍迪·艾伦在这方面做得非常、非常出色，罗伯特·阿尔特曼也做得很好。但科恩兄弟——我的意思是，你也可以拍出前者那样的作品——但我所指的、也是我的观点是，把镜头当作一个表演者，这需要付出不同的努力。没有更好，也没有更糟。这只是一个不同的工具。我只是想知道是否有一部电影……
The Cohen. Yeah. Absolutely. Like Miller's Crossing and Barton and Fink were like the two big ones for me watching stuff. But I was also watching tons of Sam Raimi's movies, you know, like, like, you know, I'm dead by dying. Stuff that was using the camera in ways that's more overtly, I don't know, fun, just kind
科恩兄弟的。对。绝对的。比如《米勒的十字路口》和《巴顿·芬克》，对我看过的作品影响最大的就是这两部。但我也看了大量山姆·雷米的电影，你知道，比如《鬼玩人》。那些运用镜头的方式更加直白、我不知道、更有趣的作品，就是把镜头到处乱甩，你知道的，一部分原因其实可以追溯到和小伙伴们胡闹，比如“如果我们把镜头绑在蹦极绳上，把它从这座桥上扔下去会怎么样？拍出来会是什么效果？”纯粹就是“如果我们这样试一下、那样试一下，拍出来的效果会是怎样的？”现在，当你去——很多人不知道这一点，但你执导过三集《绝命毒师》。你拍的时候，我确信那是因为你单纯就是那个节目的超级粉丝，就像其他所有人一样，包括我们在内的所有人。有没有那种“我多少想在上面留下我自己的印记，但正如任何电视剧导演所知，如果你的这一集看起来跟上一集有任何不同，那你就是没做好工作”的感觉？所以，你当时在那条条框框里呆着，会不会觉得很不舒服？不，完全没有。而且很奇怪，文斯——也就是文斯——他看过我的第一部电影《砖》，然后在第一季结束后不久，他给我打了电话。
of throwing it around, you know, I mean, part of that goes back to just the, the, you know, goofing around with your friends and kind of what would happen if we tied the camera to a bungee cord and threw it off this bridge, you know, like what's that going to look like? Literally just like, what's that, what's that going to look like if we try this and try that. Now when you went, a lot of people don't know this, but you directed three episodes of Breaking Bad. When you did that, I'm sure it was because you, you're simply just a big fan of that
到处乱扔，你知道我的意思，部分原因可以追溯到，你知道的，和朋友们一起胡闹，然后就会想，如果我们把摄像机绑在弹力绳上，把它从这座桥上扔下去会怎么样？你知道的，那会是什么样子？真的就像是，如果我们尝试这个和那个，那会是什么样子。现在当你去的时候，很多人不知道这一点，但你导演了三集《绝命毒师》。当你这样做的时候，我确信那是因为你，你简直就是那个剧的超级粉丝
show, like every, everybody else, we all, all of us included. Was there any sort of like, well, I kind of want to put my stamp on this, but I, as any episodic director knows, if you, your episode looks any different than the last one, you've done a bad job. So how did you, was that uncomfortable for you to kind of stay within the lines there? No, not, not at all. And also it's weird, like he, like Vince actually, he saw my first movie, Brick, and he, he called me like, I think it was right after the first season.
所以当时这部剧还没真正火起来。我签约的时候，它可不是什么大红大紫的现象级作品。所以我当时只觉得这是一部很酷的剧。但是，当剧本写得那么好，演员演得那么好，而且这部剧由文斯把关得如此扎实稳固时，我不知道——但我不知道你们在拍自己的电影时，是不是也从来不会刻意去尝试留下自己的印记——如果你刻意到把这当成一回事的地步，特别是当那是别人的东西的时候，你其实只是在尽可能有力地把纸面上的东西呈现到银幕上，还有……你有没有在你的哪部电影里客串过？没有，从来没有，从来没有。我的手总是在我的电影里出镜，但那不可避免是因为你在拍某个特写镜头，然后你要演示怎么拿起骰子之类的道具，然后你就想：“哦，把夹克给我，我来弄吧，”然后你就亲自上阵把它给完成了。但我，是的，我曾经当过一次卢克·天行者的手替，所以我就想：“好吧，每一部电影到最后我都会，我都会——”我让我的替身代劳了，我有一次因为有什么事不得不离开，当时我们正在拍一个特写镜头。
And so I hadn't like, I kind of, this show hadn't really like broken out yet. It wasn't like a big phenomenon when I signed on. So I just thought it was a cool show. And, but no, when the writing is that good and when the actors are that good and the show is that solidly defined by Vince, it was just, I don't know yet, but I don't, I don't know if you're, I don't know, or I don't think you're ever like coming into anything, your own movies, hopefully trying to like put your, if you're conscious of like putting your stamp on it to the point where that's a thing, you know, especially if it's someone
所以当时我还没，我有点，这个节目当时还没真正大火。我签约时它还不是那种轰动一时的现象。所以我只觉得这是一部很酷的剧。但是，不，当剧本写得那么好，演员演得那么好，而且文斯把这部剧的基调定义得那么牢固时，我只是，我当时还不知道，但我不，我不知道你是不是，我不知道，或者我不认为你在加入任何作品（包括你自己的电影）时，会刻意去想给它打上你的烙印，尤其是如果那是别人的作品的话
else's thing, you're just in, it was just trying to put what's on the page as powerfully on the screen as possible in, and, did you ever make a cameo in any of yours? No, I've never, never, my hand always ends up in my movies, but it's inevitably, it's because you're doing some insert shot and you're trying to describe how to pick up the dice or something, and you're just like, oh yeah, just give me the jacket, I'll just do it, and you just get in and like do it, but I was, yeah, I've been Luke Skywalker's hand once, and so it was, I was like, yeah, every single movie, I end up, I end up, yeah. I had my stand-in do, I had to leave for something or something like that, we were doing an insert.
然后他带着你的孩子们去看了棒球比赛，对吧？没错。有一个东西叫插镜头，就是你的手拿着手机，他们需要拍一个你正在看的东西的手机特写，这样就能非常近地看到你的手，所以他就照办了，结果他的手长得异常女性化，就像——比我老婆的手还要女性化。根本没法匹配。我其实——我的手长得像肉钩一样，最后我看到那个镜头时，我就想：“哦不。”
And he went into the baseball game with your kids, right? Exactly. And there was, there's a thing called an insert listener where you're, you know, your hand is holding your phone and they got to do a tight shot of the phone of what you're looking at so you can see your hand really closely, and so he, he did it, and he had these incredibly feminine hands, like, like just like more feminine than my wife. It would never match. And I, I did, I mean, I've got these meat hooks, and I ended up seeing it, and I was
马耳他的肉钩。对， exatamente（葡萄牙语：没错）。顺便说一句，肖恩，我最近遇到一个马耳他籍的家伙，他居然知道你拥有马耳他血统，我没开玩笑。对，这可是能拉得动渔网的厚实手掌，你知道的，这样网线才不会割进手指里。
like, oh no. The meat hooks of Malta. Yeah, exactly. By the way, Jason, I met a Maltese guy recently who was aware of the fact that you have Maltese origin, I'm not joking. Yeah, these are like, these are hands thick enough to pull in a fishnet, you know, so the, the netting doesn't cut into the fingers. Yeah.
这太厉害了。身边的渔夫。我们马上回来。SmartLess 获得 Visible 的赞助支持。假期意味着有更多时间陪伴家人，但这有时也意味着会有更多家庭戏剧。说起假期里的食物，你懂的，我和斯科特经常为通心粉加奶酪争论不休，比如谁做的通心粉加奶酪才是最完美的，然后当我做饭时他就站在我身后，我就说：“你能从我眼前消失吗？”
That's worthy. The fishmen on the side. And we will be right back. SmartList is supported by visible. The holidays mean more time with family, which can mean sometimes more time for family drama. When it comes to food around the holidays, you know, me and Scotty kind of fight over the mac and cheese, the most like who makes the perfect mac and cheese, and then he stands over my shoulder while I'm cooking and I'm like, can you get out of my face?
然后他就说：“哦，你用了多少黄油，用了多少……”或者他来做。然后我就会说：“那根本不对……”这简直就是一场关于谁才是最佳大厨的无休止比赛。就像在我们自己的厨房里上演一档大厨真人秀。所以，如果你无法避开假期餐桌上的戏剧性冲突，比如为黄油和通心粉加奶酪的事情争论不休，那你至少可以在手机无线套餐上省去这些抓马。通过 Visible，你只需花30美元/月即可获得一条包含无限流量的单线无线套餐，税费全包。
And he's like, well, how much butter using how much and then or he'll make it. And I'll be like, that's not, it's just a constant like competition of the best chef. It's like a chef reality show in our own kitchen. So if you can't avoid the holiday dinner table drama, like fussing over, you know, the butter and the mac and cheese thing, you can at least skip the drama when it comes to your wireless plan. With visible, you get a one line wireless plan with unlimited data for $30 a month taxes and fees included.
这意味着你无需注册家庭套餐就能省钱。再也不用担心流量超额或者分摊费用了。你不仅可以通过 Visible 省钱，而且凭借无限流量，你可以在几乎任何你想去的地方随心所欲地尽情播放视频和音频。今年，脱离家庭套餐才是省钱王道。这是一个特别的“黑色星期五”优惠。今天就登录 visible.com，在购买指定设备时即可获得高达300美元的礼品卡。别等了。
That means you don't need to sign up for a family plan to save. No more worrying about overusing data or paying your part. Not only can you save with visible, but with unlimited data, you can stream as much as you want from pretty much anywhere you want. This year being off the family plan is the way to save. Here's a special Black Friday offer. Watch today at visible.com and get a gift card up to $300 when you buy a select device. Don't wait.
此优惠于11月29日结束，需从符合条件的运营商携号转网、完成新激活以及完成三次服务付款，其他条款适用于流量管理规范。了解更多信息请访问 visible.com。SmartLess 获得 Audible 的赞助支持。你不会为了听音乐而去坐电梯，也不会为了看电影去挑航空公司。但说到音频娱乐，选择 Audible 是最明智的。这里汇集了由伊桑·霍克、凯瑞·华盛顿和凯文·哈特等超级巨星倾情演绎的故事。
This offer ends November 29th, poured in from an eligible carrier, new activation and completion of three service payments required additional terms apply for data management practices. Learn more at visible.com. SmartLess is supported by audible. You don't ride an elevator for the music or pick an airline for the movies. But when it comes to audio entertainment, it makes sense to choose audible. It's the home for stories told by the biggest stars like Ethan Hawke, Kerry Washington and Kevin Hart.
这里有史诗般的冒险、令人脊背发凉的悬疑故事以及不容错过的喜剧。Audible 是故事讲述的发源地。通过有声书、播客和原创作品让你的想象力自由翱翔。所以，如果你还记得上次我对你们说过，我迷上了斯蒂芬·金的书，那是一本多么棒的书，但现在我觉得，而且你们都知道我对科幻小说情有独钟。所以我在听 H·G·威尔斯的科幻小说合集。这真的很酷。
It's home to epic adventures, chilling mysteries and can't miss comedies. Audible is the home of storytelling. Let your imagination soar with audio books, podcasts and originals. So if you remember last time I spoke to you guys about this, like Stephen King kick I was on such a great book, but this now I'm like, you know, and you all know that I'm into science fiction. So I am listening to HG Wells, the science fiction collection. It's really cool.
里面讲了——你知道的，其中一部分是《世界大战》、《时间机器》、《隐形人》、《莫罗博士岛》，所有这些经典作品我都在听。再次强调，这真的太酷了。Audible 是故事讲述的发源地，将你所有的音频娱乐汇集于一个应用程序中。寻找你最爱的经典或发现全新的惊喜。Audible 在各个类型中都拥有令人惊叹的有声书精选，从畅销书和新书发布到名人回忆录、悬疑与惊悚小说、励志、健康、商业等等。
He talks, you know, part of it is like war of the worlds, the time machine, the invisible man, the island of Dr. Moreau, like all those classic ones I'm listening to. Again, it's so, so cool. Audible is the home of storytelling with all your audio entertainment in one app. Find the best of what you love or something new to discover. Audible has an incredible selection of audiobooks across every genre from bestsellers and new releases to celebrity memoirs, mysteries and thrillers, motivation, wellness, business and more.
作为 Audible 会员，你可以从他们的整个目录中每月挑选一本图书永久保留，包括最新的畅销书和新书发布。会员还可以完全访问不断增加的精选有声读物、Audible 原创作品和播客。你可以随心所欲地下载或收听他们包含的节目。让 Audible 帮你发现欢笑、汲取灵感或获得娱乐的新方式。新会员可以免费试用30天。访问 audible.com/smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500 500。
As an audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from their entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. Members also get full access to a growing selection of included audio books, audible originals and podcasts. You can download or stream their included titles all you want. Let audible help you discover new ways to laugh, be inspired or be entertained. New members can try for free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500 500.
也就是 audible.com/smartless，或者发送短信 smartless 到 500 500，即可免费试用 Audible 30 天。audible.com/smartless。SmartLess 获得健怡可口可乐（Diet Coke）的支持。自40年前诞生以来，健怡可口可乐就因其清爽解渴的口感而备受喜爱。这是一款美味的提神饮品。如果你被节日季的混乱所困扰，让健怡可口可乐提醒你去爱自己所
That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500 500 to try audible for free for 30 days. Audible.com slash smartless. Smartless gets support from Diet Coke. From its inception 40 years ago, Diet Coke has been loved for its crisp, refreshing taste. A delicious pick me up. If you're caught in the holiday season mayhem, let Diet Coke remind you to love what you
爱。在这个节日里啜饮健怡可口可乐，能帮你在面对强势的家人、堆积如山的工作量、节日的超负荷承诺等情况时更加从容不迫。今年，健怡可口可乐在致敬那些享受生活、而不怎么在意身边人眼光的人们。健怡可口可乐是无所畏惧地活出自我、热爱你所爱之物的能量源泉。你知道的，我所认识的两个绝对热爱并为健怡可口可乐而活的人是威尔·阿奈特和斯科蒂·“冰块”·诺贝尔。
love. Sipping on Diet Coke this season can help you confidently navigate your invasive family, toppling workload, holiday over commitments and more. This year, Diet Coke is celebrating people who enjoy life without worrying too much about what those around them think. Diet Coke is the fuel to unapologetically live your life and love what you love. You know, the two people I know that absolutely love and live for Diet Coke are Will Arnett and Scotty Ice Noble.
每年这个时候，也就是节日季前后，这两个家伙就会因为健怡可口可乐而坠入爱河并建立深厚的友谊。我每次走进房间，这两个家伙手里总是拿着一罐那个东西，咕嘟咕嘟地喝着他们赞不绝口、滔滔不绝的美味健怡可口可乐。说真的，他们对它着迷透顶。而我对他们这种着迷状态感到着迷。我很高兴健怡可口可乐迎来了它的第40个年头，因为我认为人在40岁时自信心会达到巅峰，并成为最好的自己。
And it's about this time of year around the holidays, when those two like fall in love and bond over their Diet Cokes, I can't ever walk into a room with those guys without one of those cans in their hand downing this delicious Diet Coke that they just go on and on and rave about. Seriously, they're obsessed with it. I'm obsessed with how obsessed they are. I love that Diet Coke is in its 40th year because I think your 40s are when your confidence peaks and you become the best version of yourself.
我现在就深有体会，自己刚满40岁，抛弃生活中那些“应该做的事”并纯粹热爱你所爱之物，会带来一种前所未有的自由。所以在这个节日季，和我们一起拿上一罐健怡可口可乐，去做你最热爱的事吧，无论那是什么，热爱你所爱。现在回到节目中。跟我们聊聊，当年考入——南加州大学电影学院就像哈佛法学院一样，考进去非常难。你当时是不是得经历一番软磨硬泡才能进去，还是说？
I'm feeling that now, just having turned 40 myself, there's a freedom that comes with abandoning the shoulds in life and just loving what you love. So join us in grabbing a Diet Coke this holiday season, doing what you love the most, whatever it is, love what you love. And now back to the show. Talk to us about what is, it was getting into the, I mean, the USC film school is like, you know, a Harvard Law School, I mean, it's a very difficult thing to get into. Is there a song and dance you had to do to get in there or was it?
是的。我是说，我高中时的成绩非常非常糟糕，因为我整天都在和小伙伴们拍电影，我算是个差生。所以我的成绩很烂。而且我完全没有任何人脉。因此我其实并没有考进南加州大学的电影学院，但我被这所大学录取了。我不知道现在还能不能这样，但当时你可以选择“未定专业”入学。所以我当时别无选择，而且我知道南加州大学正是我梦寐以求的地方。
Yeah. I mean, I had really, really bad grades in high school because I was just making movies with my friends all the time as kind of, it's a bad student. And so my grades were bad. I hadn't like no connections at all. And so I didn't get in actually to the film school at USC, but I got into the university and I don't know if you can still do this now, but back then you could go undeclared. And so I didn't have any other options and I knew USC was where I wanted to be.
所以我直接以“未定专业”入学了。我只是上一些通识教育课程，并且每个学期都不断向电影学院重新申请，但一次次被拒绝。我大概被拒绝了五次。直到我大三的时候，又一次被拒绝了。不过到了那个时候，我已经和一大群电影专业的学生成了朋友，而且我一直去旁听电影课。我过得挺好。
So I just went undeclared. So I just took general ed classes and kept reapplying every semester to the film school and I kept getting rejected. I got like five rejections. And finally I hit my junior year and I rejected again. And so at that point though, I'd become friends with tons of film majors and I was sitting in film classes. I was fine.
于是我转成了文学专业，并且学得很开心。然后到了第二年中期的时候。所以我不建议任何想要考南加州大学的人这样做，但我写了一封类似“去你的”信，那封信真的非常讨厌，而且非常混账，那只是一页纸的东西，当时的那个19岁的我大概就写着：“我是一名电影人。我才不需要你们的培养计划。”那真的非常讨嫌且糟糕。
So I became a literature major and was happy. And then the mid points of the next year rolled around. And so I wouldn't recommend this for anyone who's trying to get into USC, but I wrote kind of like a sort of an FU letter kind of, it was really obnoxious and really, it was just like a one page thing where just, you know, whatever, 19 year old me was just like, I'm a filmmaker. I don't need your program. And it was, it was really obnoxious and terrible.
但他们居然真的录取我了，是的，我猜，我也不知道那是怎么回事。反正是成功了。他们有教你什么吗？我是说，很多人都说，电影——在拍出一堆烂片之前，你是学不会怎么拍电影的。他们在里面教过你什么至今仍在使用的有价值的东西吗？嗯，我是说，我觉得——而且很有趣，因为其中一些人，比如我朋友的孩子们
But they let me in based on, yeah, I guess, I don't know what that was. It worked. Did they teach you anything? I mean, a lot of people say that films, you can't learn how to make a film until you make a bunch of them. Do they teach you anything in there that you still use today? Of value? Well, I mean, I think the, and it's interesting because some of them, like my friends, kids
等等，他们正在考虑是否要读电影学校，会来向我咨询，跟我聊这个。我认为电影学校真正的价值在于两个方面。首先，它其实是在你的人生中划出了一个保护罩，让你可以在这里看遍全世界的电影，并且希望能和志同道合的人一起拍出大量作品。因为我确实相信你刚才说的是对的。你无法在教室里学会如何拍电影。你只能通过看电影和拍电影来学会它。但除此之外，还有你在电影学校交到的朋友。
and stuff who are considering film school, like ask me, talk to me about that. I think the real value of film school is two fold. It's actually, it's having just a bubble in your life carved out where you can watch all the movies in the world and hopefully make a ton with you. Because I do believe what you said is right. You can't learn how to make movies in a classroom. You learn it by watching movies and by making them. But also it's the friends that, that's the friends you make in film school.
这就是为什么实际上甚至不一定非得是南加州大学。我总是给出的一个建议是，在洛杉矶读电影学校是有价值的，因为你在那里遇到的人会留在洛杉矶，那个圈子会保持完整。然后大家在二十多岁时都会互相扶持，当时我们身无分文，苦苦寻找工作，并努力拍出自己的第一部电影。不过，是的，我不知道，我确实遇到过一些好老师，但我不认为你在那里就能学会怎么拍电影。
That's why actually it's not even necessarily USC. But the one advice I always give is there is value in going to film school in Los Angeles because the people you meet there are going to stick around in LA and that circle is going to remain intact. And then you're all, we were all kind of helping each other through our 20s when we were broke and trying to get our jobs and first movies made. But yeah, I don't know, I had some good teachers, but I don't think that you learn how to make movies.
你毕业后马上就开始干了，还是说你在烤披萨，然后——不，我一直在干。我找到了一些很好的日间工作。我在二十多岁时确实做过一些非常不错的日间工作。我在一家聋哑儿童幼儿园工作，担任他们的视听设备技术员，我还曾在迪士尼频道工作，为诸如《大熊贝鲁的蓝色房屋》之类的节目制作宣传片，这让我能够勉强维持生计。但我为自己的第一部电影《砖》写的剧本，是我刚大学毕业时写的，然后
Did you get going right away afterwards or were you making pizzas and yeah. No, I was doing it. I got some good day jobs. I did have through my 20s some really nice day. I worked at a preschool for deaf kids, like as their AV guy and I worked at the Disney channel like producing promos for like bearing the big blue house and was able to kind of keep a roof over my head. But I wrote my script for my first movie, Brick, when I was right out of college and
直到我30岁时才把它拍出来。所以我基本上把整个二十多岁的时间都花在尝试并最终失败、试图把这部小成本电影拍出来上。但就是不断地去做你能做的一切，朝着那个方向前进。这也是我经常对别人说的话。你必须朝着你想要的事物那个方向前进。你可能无法立刻做到。但要一直朝着那个方向前进。是这样吗？
I didn't get it made until I was 30. So I basically spent my 20s like trying and failing to get this little movie made. But just kind of doing it whatever you could in sort of moving in the direction. That's what I always say to people too. You got to be kind of moving in the direction of the thing you want. You're not going to be able to actually do it. But keep moving in that direction. Is that right?
回想起那段时光，我也非常庆幸自己当时没有从事真正意义上的制片工作，或者类似的工作，因为我觉得那种工作给人一种“离梦想很近”的错觉，但你其实无法借此晋升到你想从事的岗位上，它会吞噬你所有的精力和时间。如果你想从事制片工作，那很好，那是一条康庄大道。如果你想拍自己的电影，我觉得，我不知道，我觉得把时间花在写作、重写自己的剧本上，拍你自己的电影，找一份能付清账单、但又不需要你每天工作18个小时的工作……
I'm also really glad looking back at that time that I didn't have a job really in like production or in because that I think that's there's an illusion of being close to it and a job where you can't actually advance into what you want to do and it sucks up all of your time and energy. And I think if you want to work in production, that's great and that's a great path. If you want to make your own movies, I feel like, I don't know, I feel like spending your time writing and rewriting your own scripts and just making your own movies and having a job that pays the bills, but that doesn't, you're not working 18 hours a day and you
不过你知道吗，我之前做过一件事。我们和——我是说，我确信你认识维塔·蒂提，他是个伟大的电影人，也是个很棒的家伙，他对我说，我们去年在做一件事的时候，他走过来说：“我们其实以前一起合作过。”然后我说：“不，我们没有。”然后他说：“不，我们合作过。”我说：“不对，我不可能不认识维塔。”然后他掏出手机给我看了一段视频，那是他当时在为 NBC 拍摄宣传片，类似于那种秋季档节目推介宣传片。真的吗？对。就是为所有那些节目拍的。他说：“我当时去现场拍了你、玛雅和克莉丝蒂娜，就是为 NBC 拍的那个东西。”我当时就想：操。
know. But you know, I saw, I did this thing. We're friends with, I mean, I'm sure you know Tyco, YTT and he's a great filmmaker and great guy and he said to me, we were doing this thing last year and he goes, we've actually worked together before. And I go, no, we haven't. And he goes, yeah, we have made. And I go, no, I would know Tyco and he brought up this video on his phone and he was shooting
这太神奇了。然后他说：“对，我当时就像是个打工的。”就像他来了，你知道我的意思吗？他当时就像是在努力……他一直在前进。这太棒了。我也有过类似的经历，那是——我想我遇到了托马斯·海登·切奇，因为我曾为《森林泰山2》拍过一段宣传片。我想是这样的。你看？对。
promos for NBC and it was like an upfront promo. Really? Yeah. For all the stuff. And he's like, I came and shot you and Maya and Christina on set for this thing for NBC. I was like, holy sh. That's amazing. And he was like, yeah, I was like, he was like a job.
对。我当时就想：“我们以前见过。”对。他们会那样的。对。你就会想：好吧。现在，在《森林泰山2》的宣传片里，我希望镜头——镜头会找到你。镜头会找到你的。
Like he was came, you know what I mean? He was like trying to, he was moving. That's fantastic. And I had the experience with, it was, I think I met Thomas Hayden church and I was able to, because I shot like a promo thing for George of the Jungle 2. I think. You see? Yeah.
好吧，你知道吗？镜头将会在丛林里。所以，瑞安，我有个关于《环形使者》的问题，我最喜欢的电影之一《利刃出鞘》也是我最喜欢的电影之一。当然。《星球大战》。《布鲁姆兄弟》。但等一下。
Yeah. I was like, we have met before. Yeah. We'll do that. Yeah. You're like, okay. Now on the George of the Jungle 2 promo video, I want the camera, the camera finds you. The camera's going to find you.
你写了《环形使者》的剧本。对于那些没看过这部电影的人来说，我简直无法想象——不过很多人都看过。但这是一个关于时间旅行的故事，你知道的，目标人物被送到过去，由受雇的杀手负责消灭他，诸如此类，对吧？然后有人威胁要“闭环”。你没看过，因为你刚才的描述听起来完全不是那么回事。我没法描述，因为它比我能用语言表达的要聪明得多。
Well, you know what? The camera's going to be in the jungle. So Ryan, I have a question about loopers, one of my favorite movies knives out is one of my favorite movies. Of course. Star Wars. Brothers Bloom. But wait a minute.
你需要视觉线索才能真正融入其中。对。对。但它太——太错综复杂、环环相扣了，我想象编写它一定是个噩梦，因为看着它时，当然，你看的时候一切都合情合理，但我当时就想：这是一个构思极其宏大、效果极其震撼的超高概念。但是你是怎么想出这个点子的？写这个剧本是不是一场噩梦？
You wrote the script for looper. I can't imagine for those of you who haven't seen that, but tons of people have seen it. But it's, it's like a time traveling thing where, you know, the tar, someone's like the criminal set in the past where the hired gun guy is waiting to shoot him or something, right? And then somebody's threatened to close the loop. You haven't seen it because the way you describe it doesn't sound like it. I can't describe it because it's more, it's more intelligent than I can put words to.
对。我其实最初是把它当作一个短片来写的。所以，我想这可能有所帮助。我在拍第一部电影之前就写好了，当时我正为筹集第一部电影的资金一筹莫展而感到万分沮丧。所以我又回到了和小伙伴们一起拍短片的状态，我们拍了几部。这就是我写那场舞蹈枪战的时候，但那是一个非常紧凑、以旁白为主导的、类似《堤》风格的短片，我想这或许有所帮助，因为它的核心创意
You need the visual clues to really get with it. Yeah. Yeah. But it's so, it's so intricate and woven and like complicated to write, I imagine, because watching it, sure it all makes sense when you watch it, but I was like, this is a super high concept that massively works. But how did you come up with that idea? And was that a nightmare to write that?
足够简单，可以用短短几页纸写完，所以把它扩充开来……难道你当时不是为普莱德拍了一堆短片吗？对，我直接切入了动作戏的核心。我希望镜头靠得非常近。不，我是说，真正的短片。哦，当然。瑞安，你擅长——我想象，我只写过一次剧本，那是我做过最难的事。
Yeah. I actually wrote that as a short. So, and I think maybe that helped. I wrote that back before I got my first movie made when I was just getting really frustrated about just thinking about money to get my first movie made all the time. And so I just went back to kind of making shorts with my friends and we made a few. And this was when I wrote the dance shoot, but it was just a very compact voiceover driven like la jete style, like short, and I think maybe that helped because the core idea of
是的。我实际上把它写成了一部短片。所以，我想这可能有所帮助。那是在我拍第一部电影之前写的，当时我只是对一直想着筹钱拍第一部电影感到非常沮丧。所以我只是回去和朋友们一起拍短片，我们拍了几部。这就是我写那个舞蹈镜头的时候，但它只是一部非常紧凑的、由旁白驱动的、像《堤》那种风格的短片，我想这可能有所帮助，因为核心理念是
it was simple enough to be written in a couple of pages and so expanding it out. So, didn't you make all your bunch of shorts for Pride when you did it? Yeah, I got right into where the action was. I wanted the camera to get up real close. No, I mean, actual shorts. Oh, sure. Ryan, are you good at, I would imagine, I've only written once and it was the hardest thing I ever did.
这个方案很简单，几页纸就能写完，所以把它扩充开来。对了，你拍《傲慢与偏见》时不是拍了一堆短片吗？对啊，我直接切入了故事的核心。我想让摄像机靠得非常近。不，我是指真正的短裤。哦，当然。瑞恩，你擅长吗？我想象过，我只写过一次，那是我做过最难的事。
I don't want to interrupt, I want you to continue this, but I'm watching Sean, he can't wait to talk about Star Wars. We're going to guess this. And I want to talk about. He's been really well-behaved. He's been really well-behaved. Just sit on your hands. He's been really well-behaved.
I have a thousand questions about last year. I know. It should be noted he's been really well-behaved. That's really hard for me to shut up. To sit in a quiet room and stare at the wall and think forward enough to know whether your idea is actually going to work and then to come backwards and start writing, I mean, that process of all that puzzle fixing with something as intricate as that, is that difficult for you or easy?
Well, no, man. It's hard. Yeah. No, you know, it's hard. I mean, I think, but the hardest thing, I mean, it's easy to make it complicated. Like as you know, it's hard to make it work, which means making it simple, you know, something complicated sort of giving it a simple enough dramatic shape to where the audience is actually going to be taken on a journey as opposed to get lost and just feel like it's math.
That's what's, that's the hard part, but yeah, but I do like structuring what's happening. Sorry, sorry, our buddies have a great time. Grandma just yelled downstairs for the kids to come up. There's the other Star Wars fan. Hey. Go put on your outfit real quick, Scotty, and come ask the question. Go grab all your figures. Bring all your action figures.
He's going to text me a question for you. So Ryan, because your stuff is so, is so tailor made, right? You write it, you shoot it at times, you edit it. Was it, was it, I can't imagine you had that much autonomy when you said yes to Star Wars. And if that's correct, was that a difficult adjustment for you to kind of do someone else's stuff? I mean, the craziest thing with Star Wars is that's not actually, it was actually just like making another one of our movies I did actually have.
Yeah, I mean, it was, I mean, yeah, it really was like kind of to a, to a crazy degree. I mean, I was, you know, it was a little different than that when I was coming up with the story. I was getting together with some folks at Lucasfilm who were like part of their story group and, but even that, it, it didn't feel like it was like a constricting. It has to be this, it has to be that. It felt like we were really just kind of talking it out and like they were kind of helping me find the direction, you know, that, that I wanted to take and then it was, it was just a wonderful process.
And then it really, even on set, it felt like, I don't know, like the actors kept saying it felt kind of like the biggest independent movie they've done. Like it had that vibe, but that, it just felt like making one of our other movies. You know, you know, one of the greatest experiences ever in my life in a theater was seeing The Last Jedi and the big reveal that Luke wasn't there. Oh yeah. Right. And the fight.
I mean, that was mine. Everybody in the theater was like, what the, everyone's head exploded. What do you mean he's not there? He's a ghost. It was crazy. It was nuts. But anyway, was that your idea, by the way? Spoiler alert.
Yeah. We'll flash that on. No, but wait. Whose idea? Like that was like never before seen in any other Star Wars movie. It was so cool. Yeah. That was that was my idea.
It was all about wanting to give Luke sort of the, I wanted him to have a satisfying moment at the end where he faced down Kylo and they had to be face to face and he had to beat him, but. And it was like a Jedi power we'd never seen. It was. I had read references to it and some of like the books and stuff. I've read stuff where I'm like, okay, this is in the realm of, of, of this, you know, this is something that has been kind of like talked about before, but we never seen it.
But yeah, but it was all just dramatically about, I need these two to face off. If they actually face off, I don't want to have to contrive some thing where one of them gets injured and dragged away or something. I know one can't kill the, I don't want Kylo to kill Luke. And so yeah, I want Luke to win. And so it was all that stuff that just led to, okay, this is the one kind of dramatic thing we can do. And so tell me about the, the, something was announced, I read about Star Wars trilogy.
What does that mean? And there's like episode one. What are we doing going back to the beginning? No, are you talking about the one that was announced that was like, I was, I was going to, that I'm going to do, if I like, or, or I don't know anything about it. It just said like, this is how Sean does it. He baits you into something. It's a trap.
Pull out. But how did that, how did that come about? How did, how did the, did you, did you raise your hand? Did they come to you? Not at all. No. They, um, yeah. No, it was, and it was, uh, it was really a direct thing.
It was, it was just Kathy kind of setting a meeting and kind of, what a phone call raising it. It really was, it was, it was literally, I walked into the room thinking it was going to be a general meeting and then it was like, shut the door behind you and, um, yeah, and it was, you're like, don't tell me what to do. And they're like, yeah, you're the guy for the job. Was there, was there an, an, an, an enormous amount of secrecy around it, maybe even an obnoxious level as far as like scripts and drafts and concept ideas.
It was, it was just Kathy kind of setting a meeting and kind of, what a phone call raising it. It really was, it was, it was literally, I walked into the room thinking it was going to be a general meeting and then it was like, shut the door behind you and, um, yeah, and it was, you're like, don't tell me what to do. And they're like, yeah, you're the guy for the job. Was there, was there an, an, an, an, an enormous amount of secrecy around it, maybe even an obnoxious level as far as like scripts and drafts and concept ideas.
And there's all this, for the listeners out there, like for certain, for certain of these, these films in Hollywood and Star Wars, obviously qualifying the Marvel stuff and all that stuff. There's these, there's these secret and secured sites to read the script on, or maybe if it's a hard copy. Everything's watermarked or digitally watermarked. Yeah. Well, the scripts are red so that you can't photocopy them, but it also means it's really hard to read them.
I mean, we had these horrible, yeah. Printed on red paper so you can't Xerox them. Yeah. Yeah. So you can't photocopy them. Xerox, you can't Xerox a red piece of paper? Cause if it's a, Stop saying Xerox has been out of business for like 40 years.
Jesus fucking Christ. You can't make a mimeograph. But if I fact something, Neil. But if I give the microfiche to the guy. So is that right about red paper? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. And we also, we had these horrible like e-readers that, um, you had to enter like a 12 digit code to get into that all the actors had to have their scripts on and it was, it was a nightmare. Yeah. It was really, well, you know, yeah, it's a real pain in the butt, but it's also, it's just kind of, I don't know, in terms of the secrecy of it, I mean, you want to preserve it for the audience, but there's also the level where it's just like people sending
drones to take pictures of like, you know, a space truck that's going to be in the background or something. It doesn't really matter. It just kind of turns into a game of, can we stop them from leaking more stuff? So yeah. But, um, yeah. Which is kind of cool. It's kind of cool.
I see that stuff like sneak onto the internet. Like it just increases excitement for stuff that's coming. Yeah. I think so too. I think so too. And I was, I grew up kind of like, you know, trolling the internet for back when the prequels were coming out in my twenties, we were all kind of getting whatever those scraps we could get it, you know, for those kids.
Knowing, knowing the, knowing the assets at your, at your disposal, the, the, the, the financing, the, the computer generated images, did any of that sort of like, was it, was it almost oddly, a, a, a speed bump to you as far as your creative, like just knowing that you can imagine something they can, they can make it, I would, that would be overwhelming to me. Like, well, how do I know what to, what to do? It's like Jerry's deli. Remember Jerry's deli?
Oh my God. Like there's no limitations. Yeah. Was that tough? It's like the diners in Santa Monica that sell pastrami and donuts and five thousand things. Right. It's the cheesecake factory menu.
Yeah. I don't know. I can't even begin. I can. But not really, because you start with it, you know, because you start with the script and you start before you have access to all that stuff, I mean, you, you start just kind of creating, um, and because we had the tight script, I guess that's the answer. We had a script that was really finished and we really went in and shot the script
and you do like any other movie you, you get on the ground and stuff doesn't work and you have to reconfigure stuff, but, um, but the reality is it was, we had kind of like I knew dramatically what we were going for with it. So no, it was never, it never felt like a, my God, we have access to all this. It felt like if we needed something, oh, thank God, we have access to this. We can make this. Did you shoot it in England with a lot of the original, uh, uh, technicians and, and yeah.
Yeah. I mean, and that was absolute. That was extraordinary. I mean, I'll tell you, just becoming friends with Frank Oz and, um, getting to work with him for, because we did one scene that had Yoda in it and I wanted it to be the original puppet. And so they found the original mold and they recreated the original. They didn't have the original puppet.
No, all this stuff, you, because this, because it, of what it was made out of, it dissolves, you know, it, it, it's not, it's not like, They're made out of toffee. Yeah. It's all toffee. I think I know where Yoda is. It's like Keen and Riddle without, yeah. Um, wait.
So, uh, but isn't it true? Like, I don't know. I just heard this. I don't know if it was Star Wars or some movie that shot over in London with the, uh, union networks over there. They all like stop working at four and they sit down and it doesn't matter where you are or something like that. That's the way it was back in the day.
So there, there was really straight, and then back, you read stories when Lucas was making the original in London, there are stories that he's crew, and also his crew despised him famously, or at least that's kind of like the apocryphal story. Cause everyone's like, what the hell is we doing this bear driving a spaceship? Like what is this? And so, right. And this young kid kind of directing it. And so, um, but no, that was kind of how it was back in the day.
The crews now in England are absolutely on board, devoted and well, and also you're dealing with people who are like us, they're Star Wars fans who are just thrilled to work through lunch. Well, it was, yeah, I mean, and, and it's, it's, it's nice because everyone's on board, but at the same time you have the resources where you're never, you know, you're never in the position where you're having to ask people to kind of, you know, live unpleasant lives. Yeah.
We will be right back. We're brought to you in part by athletic greens. I started taking AG one because I hate my countertop full of supplements and, and, and, and vitamins and all the things that I needed to line up and go one by one and open the thing and take the pill and open the thing and take the pill. This is great. It's so convenient. I love just coming, coming down to the kitchen in the morning, shaking my AG one and the
little thing and drinking it. It's done. And you know, all of the good stuff is in your body. This blend of ingredients supports your gut health, your nervous system, your immune system, your energy, recovery, focus and aging, sustainable routines are key. AG one is my daily micro habit that makes it easy to absorb key nutrients, lead a healthy lifestyle and feel my best no matter what the day holds. One scoop, one minute, once a day, every day.
You know what? To offset all the bad foodie, like the sloppy joes and the mac and cheese and the, and the hamburgers and the spaghetti and all the stuff that's delicious that I won't ever stop eating. AG one helps with my gut. It helps with the gut balance and, and so that's my, that's my go-to to kind of balance my body right now. It's time to reclaim your health and arm your immune system with convenient daily nutrition.
It's just one scoop and a cup of water every day. That's it. No need for a million different pills and supplements to look out for your health. Athletic Greens is going to give you a free one year supply of immune supporting vitamin D and five free travel packs with your first purchase. Visit athleticgreens.com slash smart list again. Visit athleticgreens.com slash smart list to take ownership over your health and pick up the ultimate daily nutritional insurance.
All right. Back to the show. I want to talk about knives out because I love that movie. And by the way, if there's a sequel or three or four, please put me in it. I'll do one line. You might want to buy newspaper. But wait. So that movie was so clever too.
In the same way that, did you write that by the way? Yeah. Unbelievable. Not a big deal. Okay. We're not an idiot. But isn't the sequel out now? Yeah.
Yeah. So, but in the same way Looper was kind of like multi-multi-layered. It seemed like such a math problem to make that story work and a modern day who done it. Like it kind of reminded me of Clue. I don't know. Probably people have said it to you. But like it was so cool and refreshing to see what's that?
Nobody's ever drawn that comparison. This is an investigative journalist. I've never met Ryan Johnson. Freaking out. And do a sequel by the way. So wait. So were you inspired by like, because people, I haven't seen like a quote, who done it or whatever you want to call the genre in so long.
Was that kind of the impetus of it? Like what is, what is my take on a who done it? I mean, kind of. I mean, I grew up loving both, I got the Christie books, but also specifically the movies that were coming out when I was a kid and that was the ones with Peter Eustonoff as Poirot. So it was like death on the Nile and evil under the sun. And I remember I have great memories of like watching those movies with my family and feeling like I was watching something very grown up and I love those films and I love the genre.
And part of Knives Out was kind of feeling like, not so much like putting a twist on it, but just feeling like I love the genre and every time you see it, it's A, usually a period piece and B, set in England, just because they're usually, I got the Christie stories and the notion of what would one look like if it was set in America right now. And doing what Christie did and engaging with the culture, you know. As a Canadian, you know, they renamed it in Canada. You probably know that. Knives Out.
Knives Out. Knives Out of town, yeah. The requisite element for films like that is obviously is the twist, is the, oh my gosh, I never saw that coming. Oh, that's who did it. That's, you are, how do you come up with your own unique like, oh, and then if this happens and that happens, like that's a certain type of a brain. Well, I mean, yeah, puzzles, but I guess kind of the big answer is sort of, I think this
is actually really important when you're doing this kind of movie is to start, is to not start with that, I guess, you kind of, because you can drive yourself insane trying to think of what's a twist that no one's ever seen before and you start coming in with horrible stuff. Like what if the dog, you know. You write backwards. Yeah, yeah. And so I think for me, a big part of approaching these movies is approaching them almost more
as thrillers where they're driven by more of a Hitchcock suspense model. That's like the engine of the narrative as opposed to a surprise based like who done it now. And then they kind of have the trappings of a who done it laid over them and they also hopefully have something at the end. But the idea is you're taking on the audience on a ride so that they kind of forget they're supposed to be solving something. And then by the end of it, there's kind of like the, they're, Daniel Craig couldn't be
further from Peter Eustonoff. I disagree. Well, but I mean, you know, he just, yeah, is he as great to work with as he seems? I think, well, you know him a tiny bit, right? I've never met him, but I know years ago we hung out with him, me and Craig, he was a lot of fun. I just hear he's just the nicest, greatest guy. Yeah.
He seems like he's like a really well-manscaped Peter Eustonoff. He's just how a lot of people describe him. Right. It's true. Not quite as breasty, but he's like a hairy Yule Brenner, I think a lot of people think of him. Now, I've asked this before of directors and really curious about it. Who do you love to collaborate with most?
Is it the operator, the cinematographer, or the first AD, or the production designer? Oh God. I mean, they're all such, I mean, you guys know they're all, I know, but you've got to pick one. You've got to pick one. Who do you have the most fun collaborating with? Of all of those folks, I mean, so my cinematographer is my best friend since I was 18. We met each other on a student film set and so, and he's shot all my movies and we're
so close. What's his name? Steve Yedlin. Wouldn't it be great if he just said, you know what, I've got a block. Ryan, that must give you a good sort of sense of, I didn't want to say that, but it's a safety net, but just, you know, that comfort of having somebody whom you really trust and you know really well over the years in that position, who's there on this ride for you, especially when the stakes get higher and higher and you're doing things where you're,
it's really a high wire act, if you will. For instance, let's say Star Wars, you know, the legacy and all of that and what's expected. And so there's a lot of pressure built into that, whether you want to admit it or not. But I'm sure you recognize that to have somebody like that, that you really trust, who's there in that moment, must give you a sense of like, I can do this and I'm going to put it in terms that Jason can understand because he wonders, it's like having a great caddy when you're playing golf, Jason. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm going with you. No, you're with him. But right, but no, but I mean, like really, truly, it must feel great having that relationship there to lean on. It's essential. And it's just right there by my side, making a movie. Sure. Christian.
Shout out. Ryan, is that true? Yeah, absolutely. Yeah. Yeah. And, you know, my cousin Nathan, who I've been making movies with since I was 10 is my composer. And, you know, I've been working with my producer for 20 years.
And I think it also, it's, you know, it's just maintaining sort of the making movies with a group of friends type feel, you know, which sounds like a, sounds like a line, but it's legitimately kind of what we've tried to build over the years is kind of our sets feel like a group of friends hanging out, you know, because they are, because we all go way, way back. I have two questions from Scotty. Bring it. Oh boy, you got a lot of emojis.
This is from a caller on the second floor. It's coming from inside the house. Okay, could you ever have imagined that a film student back in the day that you would have a film scored by one of the maestro, John Williams? I know he's amazing. And did you have a collaborative relationship with him in coming up with a new Star Wars theme? So was he like, I got this.
So he was, he was both, he was the most, like a picture like in your head, like the most incredible version of John Williams he can possibly imagine, just the warmest kindest. And he was that. Yes. Like 50%. We go every year to the Hollywood Bowl to hear it watching. He's amazing. Incredible.
Yeah. And also you go and like, you go to his, like I went to his house or the house that he works in, he still writes by hand at the piano and you look at the walls and he has shelves and they all look like they're like leather bound encyclopedias and you look closer and like on the spine of one is like Raiders. Yeah. That's so crazy. You pull it off and he's bound like the hand written like scores for all his movies.
But in answer to your question, the first time I heard any of his music was when we were on the scoring stage in a 200 piece orchestra, which there's no, but I don't need, I don't need to collaborate with John. Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. You do your thing. The London Philharmonic.
No. We did these, we did these here. We recorded these at Sony, which is still an amazing stage. It's like the old MGM stage and it's all great LA players, but we record them. Did you cry? I'll bet you'll bet you're close to tears. I was there every single day they were recording and it was just the most like emotion. I can't imagine.
Ridiculous. I went back to the Hollywood Bowl. I went backstage. I learned the theme to E.T. It's really, really hard to play and I recorded myself and I went backstage at the Hollywood Bowl and show John Williams because somebody's like, oh, you can meet him. And I showed him on my phone. I'm like, look, I'm playing E.T.
He's like, great. Oh my God. He was great. Good for you. No, he was really sweet. No, he was really sweet. Yeah. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, yes. Yeah, that was like a highlight of my life. But let's see what else Scottie says, what else color. How does that happen? Do you have a desire or I want to know this dude. You have a desire to do. Other than, other than Stowers, anything sci-fi and the sci-fi world. And if so, can you tell us like the general kind of area.
Yes, I mean, the answers, yeah. You know like alien being a haunted house movie with sci-fi or Blade Runner being a noir and yeah in that way though I yeah, I love sci-fi. I actually have a couple of ideas in the back of my head, but all right. Yeah Yeah for him, but I'll text him to him. Yeah. Yeah, you don't want to give him your phone number Hey Ryan, I know it's late. Listen just one that was your favorite Star Wars character. Hey Ryan you up This may be the Cheetos talking, but what might be great would be now you're you're obviously Incredibly Intelligent and sharp and sophisticated. What's what's the what's the dumbest most unsophisticated thing?
You do on a daily basis and this can be real housewives of Beverly Hills It can be or any of the you know not I don't want to pick on them But you know like this is any sort of reality show you watch or I have been now since and I started actually like the last week Shooting on Star Wars is when it first came out. I have been constantly playing Pokemon go Since like yeah, you shot a promo for that. Didn't you did? I shot like a commercial for one for them. Yeah Yeah, it's it's it's so dumb. Oh my god Even now even now We just are you driving around are you like are you like going out to the Santa Monica pier it's a collective?
I Have made that with my life. Yeah. Yeah, it's really it's really sad But there are there's kind of like a secret group of like adult friends I have who also play it and we have like a discord channel where we all like geek out about our it's not be a blast We won't tell anyone Please keep you keep this between us. It's just now. Are you a are you a game? Or two. Do you play games on any sort of platform at home? Yeah, you have a headset. Hang on now I don't have a headset. I don't I never I never got into them the multiplayer MP. You don't do MP
I don't I do like the story mode on stuff So like yeah, because I've tried it a few times and I was just instantly get my ass kicked by my friends So I know I always do like the story mode and kind of go through but but yeah, I've got I've got the PlayStation I guess which I've got I'm still I'm almost at the end of Zelda Breath of the Wild which is like a work of art that game But I've now stopped playing it for like four months and I need to learn how to play it again in order to anyway Yeah, it's very difficult. Well, well so much of the game is so many of these these game designers
And creators are just incredible artists unto themselves and what they create is really pretty magical stuff Well, and I feel like that with the marketplaces right now like on the different platforms the independent games that are coming out are really like Incredibly like conceptually daring and interesting and just there's a lot of cool stuff out there right now Shout out to the gaming community shout out. So so glass onion Out here. I think we're airing this probably right around the release time away There's a there's a there's another sequel that will come out shortly thereafter. Did you know back to back or no? No, I haven't written
Yeah, okay, we're gonna we're gonna put this one out and I'm gonna start writing the next one and figure it out I think yeah, yeah, I'm open to being the killer. Oh, I probably shouldn't say too late But that's that's really that's it's so exciting when we read that that they're gonna do too Are they commit to it? Did that affect the way that you broke the story for this one? Obviously, no, there's gonna be a no, yeah, no, I had ridden I had already ridden this one Actually when we kind of made the deal with them to do to do another one But it's always been in my head to keep doing and also though these it's not really a sequel It's really like another I get the Christie novel. It's a whole other cast. Oh, I said all their deal
It's just a whole new mystery. Is anybody coming back other than Daniel Daniel. Yeah, just Daniel That's it. Yeah. Yeah, and it would be the same thing for the third one So it's it's in in a way it was just kind of I would be fun to keep making these and so yeah It's really cool. Three of us are happy to send our availabilities. I'm holding you to this Sean's wearing not my favorite wig. He's got five or six other ones You should probably send you pictures of what rebel Got a rebel lion Well, we're thrilled that you joined us and yes, really really happy that you're you continue to do so well
So we can keep seeing your your work and I keep it coming, please I feel so uncomfortable that you guys have thrown praise to me. I haven't gone to gush at you guys about all the stuff I love In balance in the force right now This was this was really really kind of you guys to help me on Thanks, Ryan. Thank you so much. Yeah, you're such a talented man. Keep doing it. Keep going. Thank you, buddy Thank you. Say hi to Karina. Yeah, nice to you on when she's writing reviews of your films I'll try and tell her I love you. Must remember this. Yes
Okay, oh god, bye pal. Thank you very much. Thanks a lot. Bye Talented fellow there real real freaked out when he came out of the screen No, but you don't understand like when I never going to be in one of his films I know you committed a singular Filmmaker career suicide. You don't think I know that because of my thriving film career. I just know not true He's so wait. Listen you first, but wait Did you guys see looper? Yes. I did. Yeah Clever and like really good for words and like really yeah, he's a major
Filmmaker, I know yeah, I just but I and I remember like seeing it Oh my god, and we and we almost got like a meeting with them those is years and years ago We got to make a folder of Sean's favorite because he'll say to people it's my favorite I know by the way, I have a friend. I have a couple friends that make fun of me because I say that on here I'm like, oh my god. It's my favorite movie. I have a library of all my favorite movies Right. Yeah, I'm my little Apple thing. I'm gonna. I'm gonna just be really fax Facts you a definition of favorite and you'll realize it. Well, I meant like like there's like odds with multiple I just can't just came over the telex. What yeah, she has list, but no, but I love brought I love him
He seems like really Kind like easygoing. Yeah, very. Yeah chill very chill good guy very chill You know, I if he ever makes another Star Wars movie, you know, and I'm comfortable standing on the sidelines and just be here's the buy here's a buy stand by the smart SmartLess is 100% organic and artisan Lee handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry and Rob. I'm Jeff SmartLess Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple podcasts or the Wondry app There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他看起来真的很善良、随和。是的，非常随和。没错，很酷，非常酷，是个好人，真的很酷。你知道，如果他再拍一部《星球大战》电影，你知道的，我很乐意站在旁边，就在这儿，在这儿待命。SmartLess 是由班尼特·巴巴科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布 100% 有机且手工制作的。我是杰夫。SmartLess 的下一集将在一个星期后发布，无论你在哪里听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅苹果播客或 Wondry App 上的 Wondry Plus 来提前收听且无广告。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。